workers start by adding the raw
materials to a mixer beginning with clay
[Music]
they had a fiber derived from ground-up
rice husks this fiber reinforces the
clay giving it added strength and
helping to prevent the finished product
from cracking at high temperatures
a craftsman places the clay inside a
specially shaped mold which sits on a
potter's wheel as the wheel turns the
mold the craftsman works with the metal
arm and handheld tools to spread and
shape the clay
[Music]
he then removes the fully-formed clay
pod
the craftsman now uses a handheld tool
to define and finish the edges of the
rim and supports he then uses a metal
rectangular template to mark and cut out
a small vent for air intake at the base
of the pot an artisan prepares a small
disc of clay for a different stage of
production he uses a cylindrical metal
tool to cut a series of 61 holes in the
disc creating a honeycomb pattern that
will allow the passage of air he is a
small beveled wooden tool to help smooth
the edges of the holes when the pots are
fully formed workers transfer them to
the walk-in oven once there are a total
of 500 pots and honeycombs inside it's
time to fire up the oven to assemble the
barbecues a worker starts by creating a
layer of rice husk between the clay pot
and the zinc bucket this insulates the
metal from the barbecues heat he cuts
out the rectangular vent that will allow
air to flow into the bottom of the
barbecue and help fuel the fire
he adds soil to the gap between the pot
and the bucket to further insulate the
exterior metal from the interior heat
[Music]
the craftsman now seals all the gaps in
the barbecue was mortar in order to keep
the husk and soil firmly in place
[Music]
the honeycomb disc fits perfectly into
the bottom of the pot it will hold
charcoal up above the vent hole allowing
air to flow up through it and fueling
the fire while permitting ash to fall
down into the cavity below a worker
carefully warders the disc in place this
barbecue is a low-tech but highly
effective outdoor stove useful whenever
it's too hot to cook inside